it was a day that was Laden with
symbolism but also a certain amount of
substance if not quite as much as the
ukrainians would like probably in terms
of symbolism
um you know zelensky is described and
compared by many uh to Winston Churchill
he's referred to as the Churchill of our
times Well Checkers was the wartime
Retreats for Winston Churchill and
therefore hosted by Rishi sunak here he
took him to the room where Winston
Churchill delivered some of his radio
broadcaster in the war he took them
through the gardens and to the right of
me he could just probably make out an
Avenue of beech trees now that's an
Avenue it's called the victory Avenue it
was planted by Winston Churchill and the
Prime Minister showed the president that
Avenue as well and he invited him to
come here by Chinook helicopters so this
is a a leader a wartime president being
invited here to a place that is laid
them with symbolism at what Rishi sunat
described as a crucial pivotal moment in
this war but in terms of what help
Britain and allies can give zelenski at
that pivotal moment while we're hearing
more about things like anti-aircraft
missiles and anti-aircraft defense is
more about long-range drones that the
British are giving in addition to
long-range Precision guided missiles
they promised last time that the
ukrainians are finally getting but in
terms of fighter jets which is what the
ukrainians want most of all it's still a
bit of a long-term ambition so the the
fighter jet Pilots that the ukrainians
are sending here well only the training
for them that the British have offered
that'll only start in the summer and
Rishi sunax is still talking about this
Coalition of countries that will be
sending Jets or sending what they can to
help that that process continue so I
think that would be reassuring to the
president but he said in that uh sort of
press conference on the patio a little
earlier that at the moment Ukraine
doesn't have control of the air and
needs it and I think the question marks
remain over the timing of this much
vaunted long-awaited counter-offens of
the ukrainians are planning they now
have the tanks that were promised by the
Western that have now reached some more
than 2 200 tanks but they still don't
have that air superiority they're not
going to have for most of this year and
I think there are question marks about
that and I think the longer we wait for
this counter-offensive the more doubts
really there will be about it's uh their
ability to wage it effectively